We're taking up in volume 15, April the 21st, 1923.
And the heading is the darkest point of the present society, okay?
So just to give you a tiny bit of introduction, the 20th century is called the century of deception.
And deception is the first horseman of the apocalypse.
We've had all four horsemen of the apocalypse in the 20th century.
That tells you we're fairly far on in the book of Revelation, as Pope John Paul II told
us before he died.
Okay.
So this means that politically and religiously and every other way, things are not what
they seem.
Revelation says something is love and you pull back the label and it says lust.
It's not what it seems, okay?
And the 20th century was the century of fake.
You see a lady wearing these beautiful pearls and they're absolutely gorgeous, but they're
not worth toppings because they're only fakes, okay?
And you have that on one level and on another level you have, you can go to a party and
somebody says to you with a fake smile, you're very welcome.
And behind your backs and what the hell is she doing here?
So it's fake love.
So the 20th century is the century of fake.
So the fake news thing that Donald Trump has given into our dictionary is actually very
telling from where it came because the deception came from two ends of the world, Russia and
America, playing each other off on absolutely fake news, okay?
So Jesus is warning us about this.
So this morning, Louisa said, my beloved Jesus transported me outside of myself to a place
in which one could see flags being waved and parades in all classes of people and there
were also priests in these groups.
So this is your usual Amos 3, 7 and Isaiah 64, 10 that the Lord tells the prophets what's
going on.
As though offended by all this, Jesus wanted to clasp the creatures in his hand and crush
them.
That's a pretty strong language.
10.
So when Louisa says that Jesus wanted to crush them, that's a very strong language because
he knows from his angle what the devastation is to souls, okay?
And I taking his hand in mine clasped into myself saying to him, my Jesus, what are you
doing?
After all, they don't seem to be doing evil things.
Now notice the seam, this is the deception, okay?
They don't seem to be doing evil things but rather good things.
And this is what gets people.
It seems that the church is uniting with your enemies of before.
And these no longer show that aversion for dealing with people from the church.
In other words, Louisa can't understand at this particular moment that she's looking
at the infiltration of the church.
And now that the clergy and everything are affected, she can't see what's wrong with
it until the Lord shows it to her.
On the contrary, they call them to bless their flags.
Is that not a good sign?
And you, instead of being pleased with it, seem to be offended.
Jesus, sighing and highly afflicted said to me, daughter, how you are deceiving yourself.
This is the darkest point in our present society.
And their union means that they all have the same color.
In other words, they're all singing from the same hymn sheet.
That means that Marxist atheism has got into the church.
It means that communism has got into the church.
And by 1923, you have all the things that the pope had condemned.
You've got liberalism, rationalism, humanism, secularism and all this stuff.
It's all there.
Jesus can see it, but of course, Louisa can't.
The enemies are no longer afraid and horrified to approach people from the church, because
since the true found of virtue and religion is not in them, already some of the priests
are atheists.
Now, you know that because atheists were put into the seminaries, okay?
And on the contrary, some of them celebrate the divine sacrifice without believing in my
existence.
So they're atheists.
Now these are the communist infiltrators.
For others, if they believe at all, it is a faith without works.
Now, I want to give you James 2, 14 to 26, faith without works is dead.
And I want to give you two Thessalonians 2, 7.
And Jesus says, "Their lives are a chain of enormous sacrileges."
Isn't that absolutely frightening?
So that's why I gave you two Thessalonians 2, 7, that lawlessness is at work.
But it appears to be on their hand, because even someone like Louisa can't see it.
Now, you can't expect her to see a chair, no television, and she had no news and all
the rest of it.
So what can you see from the bed unless the Lord shows it to you?
So what good can they do if they don't have faith or hope or anything else within themselves?
How can they call others to a conduct of true Christianity by making known what great evil
sin is?
Because that's the basic thing.
They have to know what sin is in order to repent, in order to receive salvation and so
on.
That's the absolute step one.
If the life of grace is missing in them.
Now if the life of grace is missing in them, these people are living in mortal sin.
The worst thing that can happen to them is that they will die, because you know where
they will go.
With all the unions they form, there are no more men to fulfill the precept, to fulfill
the Christian law.
Therefore, it's not the union of the triumph of religion, but the triumph of their party.
So you need to put in the little word communist party.
It's the triumph of the communist party.
And masking themselves with it, that's called wolves in sheep's clothing.
Your minds will write it down, so that you actually have the expression when you're
explaining it to others.
Wolves in sheep's clothing, that's what Jesus said.
So masking themselves with it, they try to cover the evil that they are plotting.
Now what they're actually plotting is the destruction of the church.
It is true revolution that is hidden under these masks.
Now the Vatican Council brought that out, and the revolution is now out in the open.
And I remain always the offended God, both by the evil, and who pretend a shade of piety.
Now that's Matthew 6.5, Jesus condemning the pretense of piety.
Now you know from the gospel that the thing Jesus hated the most was hypocrisy, which
is pretense.
In order to strengthen their party, and therefore do graver evil, and by people from the church.
Because the communists have planted their plants in the church.
Who having a false piety, that's Matthew 15, 3 to 9.
These people honor me with lip service, but their heart is far from me.
Having a false piety are no longer good for drawing people.
You don't need the s to follow me, because you don't need the s for English.
On the contrary, it is the communist understood people that carry them away.
So in other words, the people are being carried towards this awful evil.
Can there be a time sadder than this?
In other words, the destruction of the church.
Pretense Jesus said is the ugliest sin, and you get the whole of Matthew 23 to prove it.
Jesus literally went for the jugular vein of the scribes and Pharisees because of pretense
and hypocrisy.
This is the ugliest sin.
What pretense is the true picture of Satan.
He even appears to saints as an angel of light, pretending that he's not the evil one.
And when Satan tempts us to sin, he tries to tell you that it's good.
And that which most wounds my heart, he said, is this pretense, therefore pray and repair.
Okay, so that's our introduction tonight.
April the 25th, 1923, the royal route to God, which is nice, we go from one to the other.
"I was praying, Louisa said, and my sweet Jesus came, placing himself near me in order
to pray together with me.
That's the thing we need to remember, is that when we pray, we ask him that we can
pray together with him, uniting ourselves with his prayers, with his will.
And even more, his intelligence was reflected in mine, and I prayed with his intelligence.
Now if you pray with his intelligence, you're going to be praying for the absolute best
that God wants for the world.
His voice echoed in mine, and I prayed with his word.
Now you're getting very good instruction as to how to pray here.
But who can say the boundless effects of this prayer, naturally, praying through Jesus'
intellect, through his word, through his voice, through his heart, with his prayers.
Then afterwards my beloved Jesus said, "My daughter, I wanted to pray together with you
in order to strengthen you in my will."
Now, if you wanted to know how to get strengthened in the divine will now, you know.
And I wanted to give you the grace of letting you be present before the supreme majesty
in the act of the creation of man.
As we endowed man with all goods, so that's their Genesis 2 7, or Genesis 2 actually,
with all goods, and his will was ours, and ours was his, everything was harmony between
him and us.
Now that harmony between us and God is called peace.
And that's why peace is one of the very important signs of a person living in the divine will,
because the harmony is there.
Whatever he wanted, he would take it from us.
A worldly people take it from the world, not from God, selfish people take it from themselves
and not from God.
So what would he take?
He would take sanctity, wisdom, power, happiness, and everything, all aspects of the divine being,
which of course would make us more and more and more divine.
He was our prototype.
He was our portrait, there's the most wonderful second way of describing our image.
Our portrait is wonderful.
So that's your Genesis 1, 27, and Genesis 2, 7, our portrait.
Our happy son, isn't that beautiful?
So at the beginning of his existence, Adam had a period in which he perfectly fulfilled
the purpose for which he was created.
Now perfect means complete, there's nothing left out.
He experienced what it means to live in the will of his creator.
And we also were happy in seeing our acts being reproduced in our image.
When as he broke his will from ours, he remained separated from us, but the first acts of Adam,
or man, are still in our divine will, because an act in the divine will is permanent as eternal.
And I want nothing else from you, but to come into our will to continue on from where Adam
left off.
Now we're going to have more of this, that the Lord wants us to go back to the origin
and pick up where Adam left off and continue there so that we can repair for the whole
human race, and we can substitute for them as well.
And I want you to do this so that you may bind within yourself all the harmonies that
he broke.
That's like saying, somebody has broken the strings of a guitar or an instrument, and
I want you to put them back.
And just as the first creature, because he was created by us, is the head, first and
head means the same thing.
He's the head of the whole human family.
By withdrawing from our will, he brought unhappiness to everyone because he's the source of everybody
else.
In the same way, you can come to continue from where he left off.
So we constitute you, the head of all.
Now you have to put VIP beside that, because no theologian would say that God could ever
put any woman as head.
And that's only because they don't know about the divine will.
So we constitute you as head of all.
So the blessed Trinity does that, the rest of us have no opinion.
And therefore, if you are the head, you are the bearer of that happiness and goods which
had been assigned to all had they lived in our will.
Now, he's a respondent, now, Jesus, how can this be possible?
If not even when you yourself came on earth to redeem us and to suffer so many pains,
was the happiness acquired, which the first man lost for himself and for all, how can
it be now that by binding myself within your eternal volition, I may give back this lost
happiness, it sounds completely crazy.
And Jesus said, my daughter, all times are in my hands, there's a wonderful statement.
Now, usually what the church says in the liturgy is all times and all ages, which is the same
statement are in his hands.
Therefore, he is God the Creator.
I give you whomever I want, sorry, I give to whomever I want and I use whomever I want.
Now, that's Romans 9, 14 to 18, Romans 9, 14 to 18, where Paul in his wonderful way of
saying things says that the Lord can choose anybody he likes.
And there's no point in the saucer saying to God, I want to be a cop, no point at all.
If he has made you a saucer, that's your job, you're not supposed to be a cop.
That's just my way of interpreting Paul, just a little come across simply.
So I use whomever I want and he chooses the strangest people, even me.
I could very well bring the happiness that my will contains upon the earth, but I found
no human will that wanted to live perennial life with me.
Now, perennial life is 24/7, 365.
In other words, there was nobody who wanted to live in the divine will.
So he's not talking about his mother, he's talking about the rest of us.
So as to retie the bonds of creation and to give me back all the acts of the first man
as if he had done them all with the seal of the supreme will and therefore place the lost
happiness in the field.
In other words, you've got to tidy up the house, make sure everything is in order so
that the children can live again.
Now, those of you who have rare children know, this is perfectly fine.
If you put the children into some room and let them have a wonderful time playing, they'll
make a devastation out of the room.
And when they've made a devastation out of the room, they can no longer stay in it.
So they leave it and then somebody who loves them has got to go back in and put it all
in order and everything in its right place and everything.
Then they'll go back and play again and make another devastation.
Am I talking English?
Louisa has to go back and tidy the room.
I'm just giving you very simple ideas, thoughts to try and express something which is horrendously
profound.
So you've to place the lost happiness in the field.
You've got to find it and make it available again.
It's true that I had my dear mother, but she had to cooperate with me in redemption.
In other words, everyone who was chosen has a particular purpose.
And you have to fulfill that purpose.
And none of us creatures can fulfill everything.
Only God can do that.
Besides, man was a slave, oh, that's John 844.
Anyone who sins is a slave, isn't that right?
He was imprisoned by his very sins.
He was infirm and he was covered with wounds, the most repugnant ones.
Now, that's described very well in Isaiah 35 verses 1 to 7.
And Isaiah uses different language.
He talks about the people in very destructive ways of life, but using images from the field.
And I came as a loving father to shed my blood.
So redemption had to come first before divine will.
To shed my blood in order to rescue him understood again.
I came as a doctor to heal him.
And I came understood as a teacher to teach him the way.
Now if this isn't done, there's no point in talking about divine will because this is
all preparation.
So I came as a teacher to teach him the way.
And I showed him the escape so as not to fall into hell.
Would you write the word exodus in the margin?
Because each soul has to go through an exodus from slavery into freedom.
Okay.
And that exodus, that spiritual exodus is illustrated very well in John chapter 4, Jesus bringing
the Samaritan woman out of our slavery and into freedom.
So, so each one of us has to go through the exodus.
Now the poor sick one, which is every human being, how could he extend himself in the
eternal flights of my volition if he wasn't even able to walk?
Had I wanted to give the happiness which my will contains, it would have been as though
giving it to the dead, they couldn't take it.
And letting it be trampled upon, now Jesus did say don't throw your pearls before swine.
And please don't talk divine will to people who are unconverted or who are only at a very,
very beginning stage of religion, they are not going to be able to understand one scrap
of it.
And you will get a trampled one.
He was not disposed to receive such a great good.
And this is why I wanted to teach the prayer, that's the our father, to dispose him.
And I contented myself with waiting for different eras, letting centuries upon centuries go
by to make known the living in my my will to give the beginning to this happiness.
So he had to wait until now.
So notice the patience of God, he waits centuries upon centuries.
Okay, so the next paragraph then is the royal route to heaven, that is the divine will.
So Louisa said, my love, if with your redemption not all are saved, how can it be that your
will will give this happiness to everyone?
She's logical.
And Jesus said, man will always be free, the great and terrible gift given to us is free
will.
God is the only one who will never violate.
I will never take away from him the rights that I gave him in creating God never takes
his gifts back ever, ever.
Only in redemption, I came to open many ways, small paths and shortcuts.
I love that to facilitate salvation, the sanctity of man, while with my will, I came to open
the royal and straight way, which leads to the sanctity of the likeness of their of
their creator, and which contains true happiness.
So the royal way is Isaiah 35, eight, and it's called the royal route to heaven.
And you're told that no, nothing on clean can travel on it.
Okay.
And you're also told in Isaiah that it is the root of happiness as well.
That's Isaiah 35, eight.
But in spite of this, they will always be remain free.
Some on the royal way, some on the small paths, and some completely outside.
Now that's Matthew seven versus 13 to 14, the broad way and the narrow way, okay?
And you also have a revelation chapters 21 and 22, the description of the new Jerusalem
and those who are inside and those who are outside of it.
Even at the very end of history, there will still be people inside the kingdom and outside
of it by their own choice, because we have free will.
So some will be completely outside, knows completely outside or nothing to do with it.
However, in the world, there will be what now is not the happiness of the Fiat Volontas
to on earth as in heaven.
So Jesus is saying the big difference is that for all future generations from now, there
will be people on the earth living the divine will is not absolutely fantastic.
That's going to make an immense difference.
It's going to make an immense difference to history.
Because these people have more effect on history than anybody else.
So man did his first acts in my will and then he withdrew, therefore he was ruined.
And since he was the head of all, all members were ruined with him.
My humanity formed the plane of all human acts in the divine will.
Just like saying, it formed a level of existence from which a new life can begin.
My mother followed me faithfully, so everything is prepared.
Nothing else is now needed except another creature who wanting to live continuously, perennially,
24, 7, 3, 6, 5 in my will, may come to take possession of the plane formed by me and may
open the royal root to everyone, which leads to terrestrial as well as eternal happiness.
Okay.
Now, up to now, you've heard this before, of course he keeps telling it here from different
angles that Jesus lived the divine will, Mary lived the divine will, but the rest of us
who had been born in original sin, there was nobody.
So the miracle was to raise Louisa to this level.
So then she starts the road for us.
Okay.
So it's a lovely summary of it there.
So the next one is April the 28th, 1923.
And the first line of the heading is quite a shock.
Louisa must crush the head of the serpent.
Now the only one we knew, that was to crush the head of the serpent who was blessed mother.
But you see, Louisa has now stepped into divine will.
So anybody in the divine will must crush the head of the serpent.
But very specifically, the two women who stepped into the divine will first, okay.
And then the second line is that living in the divine will is the complete triumph of
God on the earth.
So Louisa said, I felt as though immersed in the endless light of the eternal will, and
my sweet Jesus told me, my daughter, my divinity does not need to work in order to make its
works come out.
It doesn't need to actually do anything.
All he said was, let there be and it came to be.
It only needs to want them.
Now in other words, put will and desire beside the want.
He only needs to will them.
If you go to the miracles of Jesus and he decided, yes, he would work a miracle.
He'd say, I want it.
That's it.
It's done.
Okay.
I want it.
Now, so the desires in the divine will are extremely important.
It's what you actually want.
Okay.
So I want and I do let there be light and there was light.
The greatest works, the most beautiful come out of my mere wanting them as the miracles
of Jesus did.
On the other hand, even if the creature wanted them, if she does not work, if she doesn't
move, she does nothing.
Now, to one who makes my will, her own and lives in it, that's your 24, 7, 3, 6, 5,
as in her own palace, in other words, it's your normal way of living now, the same power
is communicated.
I don't know if you heard that now.
That means I want and I do as much as it is possible for the creature.
Okay.
So now we're in the next paragraph, two women have to crush the head of the serpent.
And that is to protect the rest of us who are trying to live in the divine will.
Because otherwise the serpent would knock the rest of us down, we don't have the same level
of sanctity.
Now, I was saying this, I felt myself being drawn outside of myself and I found an ugly
monster under my feet which was biting itself out of rage.
That's rather interesting, isn't it?
And Jesus being near me added, just as my virgin mother crushed the head of the infernal
serpent, so I want another virgin which must be the first possessor of the supreme will
to press again that infernal head so as to a crush it and debilitate it.
Now notice press again.
Louisa isn't doing the original crushing, all she's doing is joining blessed mother in
the crushing and then we join them.
Is that okay?
So it's a decreasing order of importance.
So to press again that infernal head so as to crush it and debilitate it in such a way
as to confine it into hell that she may have full dominion over it.
Now that to me is absolutely unbelievable and I put a VIP just beside that sentence.
And it may not dare to approach those who must live in the divine will.
You see everyone in the early stages of moving into the divine will are very vulnerable because
you're in it you're out and you're in and you're out so in the out moments the demon
will attack and you'll get huge attacks and they will be very clever attacks you won't
even know you're being attacked half the time.
So there has to be some protection there to help you to get through these slithery times
but when you come to the point where there's no space between the acts it's complete it's
it's continuous then there's no room for the demon to get in is that okay?
And that's what he's trying to tell us that you've got to fill all the gaps.
If I don't want to let water it's the pipe coming into my house and I don't want water
to come in well every part of the pipe has got to be sealed.
Not just the mouth of it because the water can come out through poles in the sides.
So the whole thing has got to be sealed.
So we have to be really protected from the evil one.
Look for sorry I'll read this again I want another virgin which must be the first possessor
of the supreme will to press again that infernal head so it noticed the again so as to crush
it and debilitate it now debilitate it because he's not conquered until the very end of the
book of Revelation so all you can do is weaken it okay in such a way as to confine it into
hell so that she may have full dominion over it and that it may not dare to approach those
who must live in the divine will so it's not just for your own protection it's for everybody
else's protection because in the divine will all the prayers are for everybody therefore
place your foot on its head and crush it.
Oh I forgot that I've only studied this and taught it a few times and I forget it every
time there's that wonderful text where Jesus says you can you can crush the head of the
serpent and it won't it can't touch you you can drink poison and you won't die do you
know that one I just it has just come to me this instant so I haven't looked it up.
So made brave Louisa said I actually did now it's easier for her to do it because she's
out of the body and she's with Jesus and it would bite itself more out of sheer rage
so as not to feel my touch now to feel Louisa's touch would be a greater hell for him than
what he's doing to himself and it shut itself up in the darkest of business now this isn't
the final conquering of him the final conquering of him is in chapter 20 of Revelation 19 I
think it is then Jesus resumed you don't say his speaking you say his message okay his
speaking isn't English my daughter do you think that the living in my will is nothing no no
on the contrary it is everything it's the fulfillment of all sanctities it is the absolute
dominion over oneself it's the absolute dominion over one's passions it's the absolute dominion
over one's capital enemies that's the seven deadly sins it is the complete triumph of the
creator over the creature there is your best answer to the question what does divine will
do for you so if the soul adheres and I come to letting her live in my will adheres is
that you persevere you continue and you go deeper and deeper because the divine will
is the supreme gift to us I come to allowing her to live in my will without her evering
again wanting her own will I've nothing left then to want from the creature and she's nothing
left to give to me I think that's absolutely incredibly important you need a big end be
over that whole piece I color it and then I put a big end be on it just to make sure
you go back and make sure that you get it okay so that when we finally give our will
to him there's nothing else that he's looking for isn't that incredible now that actually
is a summary of the entire Bible the Lord only ever asked us to do his will he never
asked anything else and the thing that human beings keep on refusing is to do his will
we find all kinds of ways around it and everything to deceive ourselves that were good and holy
while not doing his will so he said all my yearnings are fulfilled at this particular
point my designs are realized there's nothing left but delighting in each other in other
words paradise has begun it is true that I came on earth to redeem man but my primary
purpose was that the divine will my triumph over the human will by according these two
wills together which is not English by uniting these two wills together and making them one
taking the human will into that of the divine will from which it had gone out now taking
the human will into the divine will is called being divinized okay that's called being divinized
and the church has taught that from the very beginning that the Lord Jesus became human
in order to divinize us so this was the main offense that my celestial father received
from humanity and I was to compensate him for it otherwise I would not give him full
satisfaction but in order to obtain the first purpose first I had to issue the second that
was to save him to give him my hand since he had fallen now to give him my hand since he
was fallen you should have an immediate picture in your head and it's Jesus reaching out to
Peter sinking in the lake okay that's Peter sinking and so to reach out my hand to him
who had fallen to wash him of the mud of which he was lying in which he was lying so I want
to give you Isaiah 35 8 Hebrews 12 14 you're getting used to that one aren't you and Revelation
21 27 how could I say come to live in my will if he was horrid to look at there the references
and was under the slavery of the infernal enemy so as we'd say first things first okay
so in the next paragraph to achieve the purpose of redemption to he chose Louisa first of all
to receive the fullness of redemption and then the fullness of divine will that's the way it goes
therefore having obtained the second purpose he said I want to secure the first one that my will
be done on earth as it is in heaven so this is all the fulfillment of the our father
and that humanity which had gone out of my will would enter again into it but in order to obtain
this I give to the first creature that's Louisa all of my merits ring the little word all
all of my works and steps all understood my palpitating heart my wounds and my blood I give her my
whole humanity and I do it to dispose her to prepare her and to let her enter into my will
in fact first she must take the complete fruit of redemption because
entering living in the divine will is the highest level of sanctity so if you haven't gone through
the redemption part of it you can't go into the divine will so the first thing is to take the
complete fruit of redemption and the second thing as though in triumph enter the possession of the
immense sea of my divine will now look at the word possession if I possess something it is
entirely mine now we've been hearing this from Louisa since at least volume 11 and only very
slowly she grasps it bit by bit what it means to possess the divine will I do not want her to
enter as a stranger but as a daughter okay that's your Romans 8 19
not as a poor one but as a rich one not as ugly but as beautiful as if she were another
me now the another me is Romans 8 29 therefore I want to centralize my whole life in you so for
someone who succeeds in living the divine will 24 7 365 Jesus is living his actual life in you
that's the miracle and while he was saying this it was as though many seas were coming out of
him which poured upon me now when you say many seas it's all the grace and sanctity and wisdom
and everything else that he's been talking about and I remained inside of them sunken
that's like a drop of water in the ocean no they're different that's why I said a sea of wisdom a
sea of grace it's all the ones he's been talking about in the last couple of messages
so it's sanctity wisdom grace and all his attributes okay the sun is completely different
because you're talking there about light yes it's a different subject you'll come to that in a minute
though you're never very far from the sun in these writings so I have to centralize my whole life
in you oh yeah so Louisa said while he was saying this it was though many seas were coming out of him
we say that blessed mother was a sea of divine grace now another way of saying that is an ocean
another way of saying that is an enormous capacity okay
we're coming out of here and pouring into me and I remained inside of them sunken and at the same
time a sun now notice it's different from the sea a sun beating down with its light as a different
concept altogether because the sun represents God and God is light okay receiving the complete
fruit of redemption now I gave you usually when I'm talking about light I only give you one reference
and I decided to repent and go and do a bit of exercises so if you want a couple of references
for God is light a surprising one for me was Isaiah 60 this is God is light this is the sun
okay Isaiah 60 19 to 20 that's an absolutely lovely one and there's also Ezekiel 1
Ezekiel 1 27 to 28 Ezekiel like John in Revelation is one of the only people in the Bible to try
and describe God and he describes as a men's light there's also Habakkuk 3 3 to 4 you see I've
been doing a bit of exercises Habakkuk 3 3 to 4 I said Lord I've been very lazy I give them just
the same reference all the time and therefore they think it's the only one you know
so now it was a sun beating down with its light receiving the complete fruit of redemption
so this sun is therefore representing God the Father receiving redemption you see it
in order to be able to give the complete fruit of its will to souls I think it's better to say that
it was the son of the eternal volition which of course is the essence of God
which celebrated the entrance of the human will into its own now usually before the divine will
was revealed human souls only entered into the divine will with death but now the miracle is
that to do it while around the earth and Jesus said this divine will of mine grew with my humanity
like a flower why because he had to grow in age wisdom and grace before God and man do you remember
that so that's Luke 2 and it's around 35 which I transplanted from heaven into the true Eden
of my terrestrial humanity now Eden represents paradise paradise means not a beautiful garden
on the earth but it means total harmony with God and he said his humanity was that true garden of
God so this seed of the divine will germinated in my blood it sprouted from my wounds to make of it
the greatest gift of the creature and don't you want to receive it and so we all say with Louisa
yes we do and he said well I want to transplant it into you love it and know how to keep it
isn't that beautiful so the stuff there that you really need to sit with and you can get a certain
amount on a first reading but I find that on the tenth reading you'll say I didn't understand it
the first time so we're talking about the our father on May the second 1923
so the fiat volunteers tour or the our father has its fulfillment on earth as it is in heaven
in the divine will so Louisa said I felt my poor mind as though dissolved in the immensity
of the divine will and my sweet Jesus returning to speak about his most the most holy will of God
said to me my daughter how well your acts done in my will harmonize this is very important
they harmonize with mine because it's the same will with those of my blessed mother because it's
the divine will and one disappears within the other forming one single act it seems that heaven
is on earth and the earth is in heaven okay because the divine will is in heaven and is now
in these human beings on earth and the echo of one in three and of three in one of the most holy
Trinity okay so one divine will in heaven one divine will Jesus Mary and Louisa on earth
so you have a Trinity in both cases oh how sweet it sounds to our hearing
how it enraptures us but so much as to capture our will from heaven to earth and when my
fiat volunteers to has its fulfillment on earth as in heaven then will the complete fulfillment
of the second part of the our father give us this day our daily bread this is VIP underlying 10 times
we all want the second part first gimme gimme gimme okay but he says no no no there is an order
you have to fulfill the first part and then the second part will kick in
okay so Louisa said our father in the name of all i ask you for the three kinds of bread
every day now what are they the bread of your will or rather more than bread bread here means
nourishment for life because bread was the staple diet of the poor
if it was Arlyn Giuseppe potatoes in the past so the bread of your will so that's the divine
nourishment or rather more than bread because if bread is necessary two or three times a day
you see that's the diet of the poor this one is necessary at each moment and in all circumstances
even more it must be not only bread but like balsamic air that brings life
the circulation of the divine life in the creature
now it must be air i've told you before if you listen to me for a second
yeah that's the name they gave to god yeah is the outbread and way is the inbread so
the name they gave to god is he is my bread is that okay so that's what that's what being spoken
about here at this balsamic air that gives you life is that all right um so you can write
Yahweh beside that and you'll remember what i said he is my bread
and the bread of god is ruok or uac h adonai adonai and the bread of god ruok adonai is
the holy spirit okay the bread of life the bread of god so father if this bread of your will is not
given i will never be able to receive all the fruits of my sacramental life which is the second
bread we ask of you every day so the bread of the eucharist
oh how my sacramental sacramental life feels discomforted because the bread of your will does
not nourish them on the contrary it finds the corrupted bread of the human will now bread is
being used all the time as nourishment i'm being nourished by self will okay oh how disgusting it is
to me and how i shun it and even though i go to them i cannot give them the fruits the goods the
effects the sanctity of the eucharist understood because i don't find our bread in them that's the
divine will so without the divine will we're not able to receive all the fruits of the eucharist
and if i give them something it's in small portion according to their dispositions
but not all the goods which i contain so he can only give us what we're actually open to
but if we're in the divine will and receive in the divine will we're open to everything
and my sacramental life is patiently waiting for humanity to take the bread of my supreme will
in order to be able to give all the good of my sacramental life
see then how the sacrament of the eucharist and not only that one but all the sacraments left to
my church and instituted by me will give all the fruits which they contain and complete fulfillment
when our bread the will of god is done on earth as it is in heaven i think that's a very important
explanation of the our father isn't it yeah so louisa said when i asked for the third bread
the material one how could i say give us this day our daily bread i could do so in view of the fact
that as man would do our will it wasn't louisa's jesus saying it uh what was ours would be his
and so the father would no longer have to give the bread of his will the bread of the sacramental
life and the daily bread of the eucharist to illegitimate usurping evil children wow
but to legitimate and good children is that amazing okay now the illegitimate usurping
and evil children that's people doing their own will and therefore they could even be sinning in
receiving communion because if you're the wrong dispositions and everything so this is why i said
give us our bread then they will eat the blessed bread everything will smile around them and heaven
and earth will carry the mark of the harmony of the creator so there's no way that we can open up
to the fullness of what god wants to give us unless we open up to the fullness of his divine will so
if we open up to the fullness of the divine will he provides everything we need spiritually
and temporally so all our needs are bread that all our spiritual and temporal needs are actually
taken care of so when we come to the next important piece in the our father after this i added forgive
us our debts as we forgive our debtors now the people thing that people forget is the as we forgive
so if i don't forgive i'm telling god he's off the hook he doesn't have to forgive me
because i don't forgive anybody else that's the bit of christianity that as far as i'm concerned
an enormous amount of christians do not understand so i hold resentment against somebody i am actually
very severely breaking god's law because resentment is the exact opposite of love
and so if we don't operate forgiveness we're actually not even doing the basics in terms of
christianity so charity that is divine love but love for your neighbor and love for your neighbor
is shown more frequently in forgiveness than in anything else if we even forgive them from the way
they think and if they forgive them from the way they for the way they act and for the way they
believe or don't believe or anything else we forgive everything so charity also will be perfect once
humanity has eaten the bread of my will as my humanity ate it then will forgiveness have the
mark of heroism as i had it on the cross then will the virtues be absorbed into my will
so they will be divanized they won't just be human virtues they won't even just be supernatural
virtues they'll be divine and they will receive the mark of true heroism and of divine virtues
i'd underline the divine virtues if i were you and they will be like many little rivulets
which will gush forth from the bosom of the great sea of the divine will
so notice everything has to be divanized it was then i added lead us not into temptation
how could god ever lead man into temptation that's one of the controversies we've had recently
when the pope wanted to change it to its correct wording which has lead us not into the test
okay temptation is a wrong translation but as soon as the pope even suggested using the correct
thing there was roars going off from all over the world that he was changing the our father and he
wasn't not at all anyway how could god ever lead man into temptation it was because man is always
man he's always free in himself since i never take away from him the rights that i gave him in
creating him that's his free will and he frightened and fearful of himself tacitly cries out
and prays without ceasing give us the bread of your will that we may reject all temptations
and by virtue of this bread deliver us from all evil is that very interesting
so the next paragraph tells us that everything is in the our father
see then how all the goods of man find again their connection and the close it's my books as tight
bond we i think we say close for bonds and the close bond of the uh let us make man in our own
image and likeness the validity of each of his acts the restitution of the lost goods as well as
the signature and assurance of his lost happiness both terrestrial and celestial will be given back
to him therefore it is so necessary that my will be done on earth as it is in heaven that i had no
other interest nor did i teach any other prayer than the our father and the church faithful executor
and a pository of my teachings has it always on her lips and in every circumstance and everyone
learned and ignorant little and great priests and people kings and subjects all pray that my will
be done on earth as it is in heaven and as you know already he needed the bank of two thousand years
of praying the our father with all the sacrifices and sufferings and all the rest of it of that two
thousand years for him to launch the new era now do you not want then that my will descend upon the
earth but just as redemption had its beginning in a virgin as blessed mother as i was not conceived
in all men in order to redeem them even though whoever wants it can enter the good of redemption
and it's the same with divine will once louisa has completed everything we can enter in and
take as much as we want in the same way now my will must have its beginning possession growth
and development in one virgin creature now virgin means untouched by any other idea
any we're inclined to think that virgin only refers to body okay but if you look at the people
whom god has called throughout history children who would not be affected by all the thinking of
the day they wouldn't have heard all the philosophers and the sages and they wouldn't have heard all
the theories and all the doctrines and everything they're they have virginal thinking you know and
you have a virgin soul it's not just virginity is not just in the body having a virgin soul is
much more important so what louisa is a virgin in the body as well so and that's because the lord
wanted someone very very pure so it must have its beginning possession growth and development
in one virgin creature and then whoever disposes himself and wants it does your free will well enter
the goods which the living in my will contains and it's like walking into a supermarket there's
everything there you're not going to take everything but you will select what you want
and the thing is other people select different things and therefore between us all it all gets
done and had I not been conceived in my beloved mother redemption would never have taken place
in the same way if I do not operate the prodigy of making one soul live in my divine will the
fiat volantis tour on earth as in heaven will not take place in the human generation so that's simple
okay so may the fifth 1923 we're talking about entering into the divine will he's a very good
teacher you know he keeps on giving you revision lessons uh so finding myself in my usual state
I felt drawn outside of myself Louisa said and I but I couldn't see the asier heavens
nor the sun in our horizon but I saw a different heaven all of gold studded with stars of various
colors more effulgent than the sun I felt drawn up high and in this heaven opened before me I found
myself in front of a most pure light now you use the new references for your light okay
and and before this light which of course is the divine will I prostrated myself I called all human
intelligences into my intelligence from the moment in which Adam began to break the union
of his intelligence and with that of his creator by withdrawing from the divine will up to the last
man who will exist on the earth now she was told to do that wasn't she go back to where Adam left
off and pick up the thing and I tried to give to my god all the honor the glory the submission
etc of all created intelligence and I did the same for all the other senses calling all those of
other creatures into mine all this always in the divine will in which everything can be found
and which nothing can escape you see the way you're being told the most profound way to affect the
human race to pray from within their own intelligence from within their own senses from within their
own soul within their own but it's it's fascinating uh she said even things that may not exist at the
present moment and in which everything can be done so I could give you a mark 11 24 to 25 nothing is
impossible with god mark 11 24 to 25 so while I was doing this louisa said a voice came out from
within the immensity of that light saying as many times as the soul enters into the divine will in
order to pray work love etc so many ways or paths we would say does she open between the creator
and the creatures is that amazing and in seeing that the creature is making her way into the divine
will the divinity opens its paths I think path is a better word in order to meet its creature
in this encounter she copies the virtues of her creator she absorbs ever new divine life into
herself she penetrates more into the eternal secrets of the divine will and everything she does
is no longer human in her but divine this divine operating forms a golden heaven within her
the golden heaven is inside of you she did notice she wasn't looking at something outside
so he says this golden heaven is within you this is the kingdom of god
Luke 17 21 the kingdom of god is within you and it's a golden heaven because it's at the
highest possible level of existence Luke 17 21
so she finds this golden heaven within her on which the divinity strolls Proverbs 8 31
god delights to be with the children of men in other words this is a place that god can feel
at home in okay delighting to find its own operating in the creature awaiting the creature
in order to receive her divine acts and therefore open more paths for her in its divinity okay
now therefore this golden heaven has to be one Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the
temple of the living god and god dwells in you and the divine will keeps repeating with great love
behold here is how in my will the creature comes closer to my likeness she accomplishes my designs
she fulfills the purpose of creation and then louisa came out of the ecstasy is that amazing
so you've been given a very good summary there of how it works when we enter into the divine will
and the divine will finds a home in us that everything that he wants to do in us and in creation is
fulfilled it's fantastic so may the 8th 1923 we're going back to our origin as i was in my usual
state i found myself outside of myself louisa said i seemed to be covering a very long way that's
very interesting because down in volume 36 just as she's going back to god she'll say
i'm on a very long way she had to traverse the whole way for us we would call that blazing a trail
for others to follow i seem to be covering a very long way blazing a trail i think speaks to us
clearer on which i encountered many people somewhere horrifying to look at some seem to be incarnate
demons very few of them were good this is the journey back to god okay that way was so long
that it would never end and i tired wanted to go back into myself but someone who is near me
prevented me from doing so telling me come now keep going you must reach the beginning
that's the beginning of creation that is a long journey so she's meeting all kinds of creatures
on the way back and in order to get there you must go back you need to add that word through all
generations you need to go back through all generations you must have them all under your
eyes so to bring them to your creator your beginning is god and you must reach that point
of eternity in which the eternal one created man in order to receive all the bonds of creation
and to retie all the harmonies that exist between the creator and the creature so that's twice or
three times you've been told that tonight okay so a supreme force made me go forward
and i was forced to see the evils on the earth and those that will come that is from the 21st
century onwards she was able to see backwards and forwards you see this explains what Jeremiah said
to Hananiah in the book of Jeremiah where he said have you been in the council of god if you've been
in the council of god you will know what god has what god sees and what god wants Hananiah
had never been in the council of god with Jeremiah had so this woman is in the council of god and
she sees what god sees it's very frightening for a little person so she said unfortunately she said
most of it was horrifying because if you read the bible quickly history isn't funny then after this
I found my sweet Jesus and tired I threw myself into his arms telling him my love what a long
way I had to go through it seemed centuries without seeing you which is correct because she
was going backwards and without finding the one who forms my life and Jesus all love said
understood ah yes my daughter rest in my arms that's Sam 131 come into your beginning from which
you came that's you is the creation of man I too was anxiously waiting for you to receive from you
in my will all that creation owes me and to give to you in the name in the same divine will
all that I must give to creation my will alone can place in safety and keep with jealousy all the
goods which I want to give to the creature outside of my will my goods are always in danger and
poorly kept while in it I abound and I give to one what I should give to everyone Matthew 25 28
remember you give the ten talents to the one that used the thing not the the person who refused to
use the talent to him who has will be given more do you remember that so this is why I want to
bind all creation in you he said I want to place you at the original point okay of the creation of
man it is my usual way to deal one on one with one creature alone we don't one creature only we say
what I want to give her and what I want from her and then from her I let the goods derive for others
so the whole plan is completed in one person and once the plan is completed the the bank is set up
another people can come to the bank and get what they want and my daughter I had created man like a
flower which was to grow a choir color and fragrance in my very divinity by withdrawing from my will
it happened to him as to a flower which had been snatched away from the plant as long as it remained
in the plant the flower was beautiful lively in its color and fragrant in its perfume but once it
is snatched away from the planted withers it fades and becomes ugly and reaches the point of giving
off a bad smell what a lot this was for him we would say what a fate this was for man and what
a sorrow for me who with so much love wanted to raise this flower in my divinity to delight and
amuse myself and him so we're the flower if we stayed in the divine will we would reach fullness
coming out of the divine will we fade now in my omnipotence I wanted this detached flower to bloom
again by transplanting it once again into the womb of my divinity but I want a soul who wants
to live in the womb of my volition and what the lord needs are as people who actually want to live
in the divine will that's that's what he's looking for because if you want to live in the divine will
he can work with you she will be the seed and she will lend to me and to my will and my will will
do the rest so she will be the seed okay I will enjoy myself with this mystical flower
and I will be repaid for creation okay so you remember Jesus said in john 1224
unless the wheat grain falls to the ground and dies it'll produce nothing so that's why he has to
let the whole mystery of redemption work its way through us so that it can flower and the fruits
can be given to everybody else okay so what I have written down here in my book april the ninth of this
year it said the our father was the seed of hope for the kingdom of god so the kingdom of god would
come so here you're told that louisa is the seed of the recreation of humanity in restoring it to
its original state now the word seed can be used of different things Jesus calls his word a seed as
well and it's just important to know that the same word can be used for different things
is that all right so I'll just give you one more tonight
so may the 18th we're going to talk about self-sacrifice
I was feeling all afflicted and almost without my beloved Jesus what a hard martyrdom is his
privation a martyrdom without the hope of storming heaven like the martyrs do
which renders their very suffering suite his privation instead is martyrdom which disunites
burns cuts and opens an abyss of separation between the soul and god now the description
that's given there is a description of hell an abyss of separation between the soul and god
now on our next gathering and during the 29th I'm going to talk to you a little bit about that
because the lord has shown me how to explain it I won't do it now she calls this
privation a martyrdom which instead of sweetening suffering embitters it
intoxicates it in other words it's so intense in such a way that while the soul feels herself
dying death itself runs away from her when I was in this immense abyss of the privation of my
Jesus he just barely moved in my interior I said to him oh my Jesus you don't love me anymore she's
been at that for 15 volumes and he not paying attention to me why should he after 15 volumes
he's explained it endlessly to her made himself seen all afflicted as though holding a black
thing in his hand which he was about to throw upon humanity then he took my heart in his hands and
he squeezed it tightly pierced it through and my heart anxiously awaited his pains as refreshment
and bam for the pains it had suffered in his privation now it's only here that you'll get that pain
could be the bam for other pain but I will explain that to you and on as they say so pain relieves
pain now down at my level pain wouldn't relieve pain I don't know what level you're on okay but
this is the level she's at okay but it will make sense when I managed to give you but I'm not going
to say it now because it's not a few words it's going to require a talk so his pains as refreshment
and bam for the pain suffered for his privation oh how I feared that he might cease to make me suffer
this incredible plunging me once again into the abyss of his separation now what she's saying is
when I'm suffering the crucifixion he's always there and if I'm not suffering the crucifixion
he's not here so she chooses the suffering of the crucifixion to have him there that's clever isn't
it okay watch his response to this it's fascinating after this he said to me my daughter I don't pay
attention to words but to facts this is very important because lots of people can say oh my god
I love you you know we have this prayer the stab at matter you know holy mother pierce me through
and people sing it and everything I wouldn't say that because I actually know what I'm saying
so there's lots of things in hymns I actually passed by I said I'm sorry I couldn't do that
and I go to the next line what many people just sing away they don't realize pierce me through
I mean what would we think enough I always remember a conference I spoke at and maybe I
tell you afterwards you remind me okay we come to this he said I only listen to facts not to somebody
fervently saying something to me you know I would die for you and you wouldn't even do he's will
do you think it's easy to find a soul who really wants to suffer oh how hard it is he said
with words yeah there are many who want to suffer but with facts they run away when the first
pain or presses them and I'm in suffering surround them as we say we are on for the pannadol
oh how they would want to free themselves and I remain always the isolated Jesus in pains
now this is his reaction to Louisa Louisa's speaking in the first paragraph
okay this is why he said when I find a soul who does not shun suffering and who wants to
keep me company in my pains even more she waits and waits for me to give her the bread of suffering
bread is nourishment now we don't think of suffering as nourishment do it
no we have to go a little higher for that but that's Isaiah 30 20 the bread of suffering
and Isaiah actually uses that expression as well the bread of suffering this gives me the delirium
of love and makes me reach the point of doing follies and of abounding so much with this soul
as to astonish heaven and earth do you think it was something indifferent over my heart which
loves so much that while you were without me you were waiting for me for nothing else but to receive
from me bitter pains Louisa doesn't even know she was talking about heroic love didn't even know
what she was okay and then we have the opposite in the next paragraph priests who killed souls
instead of shepherding them is the next paragraph but while he was saying this he made me feel
that the most blessed sacrament was passing by on the street you see and he gave a stronger
squeeze to my heart and Louisa said my Jesus what what's going on where are you going and who is
carrying you and Jesus said I'm going to a sick person and I'm carried by an executioner of souls
that's a priest Louisa was all frightened she said Jesus what are you saying what your ministers
executioners of souls and he said yes how many executioners of souls there are in my church I
mean this is scary out and it's a century ago there are executioners attached to interests
that's the vested interests we've been at this now since volume one the vested interest thing
who make a slaughter of souls because they turned them to worldly people who would their
example instead of rendering souls detached from all that is the of the earth they engulfed them
even more because if the priest is doing it everybody doesn't there are the immodest ones
who instead of purifying souls disfigure them
number three there are the executioners of pastimes dedicated to pleasures to strolls
I love the strolls but and to other things who instead of rendering souls recollected
and infusing in them love for prayer and retreat they distract them all these are slaughters of souls
he said how much pain does my heart not feel and seeing that the very ones who were to help to
sanctify souls are the cause of their ruin so for that I want to give you again Matthew 15 1 to 9
and Matthew 23 15 and just put a CF revelation 11 18 I will destroy the destroyers of the earth
so i'm going to stop at that very delicate point okay